b12 shots versus over-the-counter
tablets can modern science cure a
hangover we've created a facility to
test the world's greatest hangover cures
and we're gonna test of all I'm dr.
Keller wertham the doctor of internal
medicine I'm Fran Kranz I'm not a doctor
but I've been hung over a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover laughs so
what do you guys do what are your
occupations I'm a nail artist I am an
event photographer we're gonna check out
what you guys did last night me and my
first bartender of the night I'm a
martini drink martini drink yeah I mean
like a martini is not a bad choice if
you're looking to avoid a hangover cuz
it's just vodka not a lot of what we
call those congeners that are the other
toxicities that certain alcohols have
and you get a little bit of you know
olive oil or honey now we're doing shots
and now we're at wow this was a quite a
night guys you know we ran some baseline
tests vital sign wise you know really
the most remarkable thing for y'all is
your urine concentrated spilling some
bilirubin which means your liver is not
really happy right now
on the breathalyzer test you saw you're
still actively metabolizing alcohol we
did some simple fifth grade level math
questions 49 plus 84 oh God it has ready
for cure yeah in my professional opinion
there beets they they came in they're
struggling they're both having a lot of
trouble with the light I mean it's the
Sun glass pounding headache they're
having a hard time they're looking
pretty rough but you know we've got a
couple of cures on deck today that I'm
I'm interested in because these at least
are approximating some some yeah medical
background yeah yeah we got b12 shots
and then we got over-the-counter tablets
the effervescent tablets I'm more
excited about because these are a
combination of caffeine which has been
shown to increase alertness and also
reduce the activation of this chemical
in the brain called adenosine which is
what gives you a headache they also have
aspirin and aspirin has been known to
block
those chemicals that just cause pain in
the body that are very elevated with a
hangover and then we've got the b12 shot
I gotta admit here b12 is certainly a
vitamin that plays in alcoholism and
alcohol consumption because when you
drink a lot of alcohol your b12 levels
drop
so taking b12 makes sense however to
give a b12 shot and expect that
someone's gonna feel better from it
immediately just biochemically really
doesn't make sense come on in have a
seat so here we have a b12 shot and here
we have an effervescent tablet and we're
going to give you a couple of them so
Natalie are you ready for a b12 shot I
am okay I'm gonna give you an injection
you jealous Tommy are you just sounds
pretty nice right now
ya know it's time for you there you go
down the hatch how does it taste so
we'll let you guys rest for a little bit
and then we'll sit down and we'll talk
about how you guys are feeling a little
bit about 110 over 75 point out for your
blood pressures exactly what for good
0.05 let's go back take another we got
four before fifth grade level math
questions last time we're warm-up and
improve 2+2 115 - 1798 120 times 3 360
20 times 32 640 15 plus 18 33 149 round
into the nearest 100 500 if John has 3
pet turtles in jake has 9 pet turtles
how many pet turtles are all together
I think that's 12 yeah it's 12 pet
turtles turtle yeah so let's talk about
it and talk about it
so the brew departs over you see more up
more in a few actually a lot a lot
better I'm curious to know how you felt
the vitamin b12 shot work it worked
really well I don't know I'm just more
alert and more aware of my surroundings
well yeah I just feel better you know
that that's habit had caffeine in it and
caffeine has been known to block some of
the alcohol induced headache event so
that makes sense yeah I do feel better
than I did last time I asked why I just
have to start by saying I'm wrong
Natalie looks great and it just hurts me
to give it a good grade cuz I don't get
it I'm gonna have to give the the b12 a
B+ nice b12 b+ I just because she looks
so okay and I'm gonna have to go back to
med school and figure out why well some
things I
ion's can't explain right it was true
some mysteries in the universe it's true
I'm gonna grade the the effervescent
tablet at I'm gonna give it a B+ okay
from what I saw Natalie was like a
different person
no I'm gonna go a minus for the b12
b-plus for the tablets I'm Fran Kranz
I'm dr. Keller thanks for coming to the
GQ hangover lab for more hangover cures
subscribe to our channel or like us